empowering young girls young women to
become really at women that starts with
a changed paradigm about how we see
young people in general see them as
leaders as change agents who are moving
our culture forward that's actually what
adolescent rebellion is all about it's
about breaking the mold of the previous
generation and moving the culture
forward so starting to see young women
and men in that way rather than as rowdy
teenagers who need to be managed and
shaped and guided by us so how do we
teach girls to manage their inner
critics we're all hardwired to have an
inner critic the inner critic is just
the voice of fear within us a voice that
really doesn't want us to ever stretch
out of our comfort zone ever get hurt
ever feel embarrassed it's that voice
coming up with all kinds of arguments to
keep us playing small so that those
things never happen and so the arguments
it comes up with or you aren't smart
enough or you aren't good enough or that
was so stupid how could you say that and
actually all we really need to do to get
the inner critic out of our way is to
realize what it is that it's an
irrational voice that actually has no
bearing on the truth and to label it for
what it is and then also teaching them
that the world isn't finished yet in
fact the world has a hole in it that is
shaped exactly like them and only by
their own sharing their voice and
bringing their unique gifts into the
world will that hole be filled so if
they ever feel alienated by the world
like their point of view somehow just
doesn't fit in some sense they're right
their point of view is missing but
that's because the world has a hole in
it that's shaped just like them and it
needs their voice to fill that hole